quoi nous n'arrivons nous ne ferions pas
comme aux états unis avec une sécurité
sécurisation par miradors et
possibilités effectivement ne pas se
poser de questions et quand une
intrusion de tirer questions et
propositions chocs de la députée l air
en marche vers une douleur au ministre
de l'intérieur gérard collomb lors de la
commission d' enquête sur la sûreté et
la sécurité des installations nucléaires
tiré pour protéger les centrales le
propos c'était on a à l'intérieur un
peloton de ces cures de gendarmerie qui
est le grade en dessous du gel non qui
est formé comme il le faut est-ce qu'il
faut pas qu'ils utilisent les armes
quand il ya besoin de neutraliser leurs
pas tué mais neutralisent au niveau des
gens quand on sait pas qui c'est
l'ancien chef de projet de la centrale
nucléaire de belleville sur loire dans
le cher évoque le traitement particulier
dont bénéficient les militants de
greenpeace lors d'intrusions
ça m'a interpellé quand on se dit est le
petit terroristes qui vient qu'une
bonbonne greenpeace et peut rentrer donc
un moment il faut quand même qu'on est
un moyen de
d'intervenir enfin voilà et c'est pas
intervenir n'importe qui c'est des
gendarmes qui sont formés à la
neutralisation et la neutralisation
c'est pas forcément tués